[Music]
how many of y'all have seen the tiger
King me no spoilers please Emily see the
whole thing weird I see the whole thing
did you know we did a JK news about him
when a long time ago yeah what fans kept
sending me [ __ ] they're like dude you
guys did JK news on this guy ages ago
what's craziest people people are like
posting now because the documentary
became so famous of like him when he
show up for their schools to teach them
about drugs and stuff what people like
yo this is a guy that like this he's
kids he's been like crazy for years and
years but I guess now everyone knows him
I don't remember me I don't know I
probably wasn't around when you guys
reported on him like Joe exotic right
cuz his name always dull exotic that's a
stage name yeah but I mean back then
corn into the documentary he changed his
name to Joe exotic the moment art
performing magic retire yes so that's
probably big jugs Ark for a long time
yeah true now I know why you guys tell
you about me I think he's you - the gay
part it's you dude well - according to
some fans plus the gay part whatever
makes him him there's a conspiracy about
me oh do you know anything about him
zero man everything a trailer no like I
literally as soon as I got back I've
been so [ __ ] busy non-stop I haven't
opened up ozark netflix anything could I
tell you something about him that makes
him wonderful but it's an awesome Deena
discovered in the show though oh do you
say [ __ ] it I'm gonna forget okay this
guy he's so magical he doesn't have just
one husband he has two husbands and he
convinced him to get all married at the
same time so when he got married he was
in the middle and then he kissed one and
he may but you got you got to another
part apart no spoilers but da just tell
us the other part that makes that even
crazier
what part of
oh they were oh you didn't finish it I
didn't finish it
now that mean makes so much sense don't
say [ __ ] doesn't mean that goes around
our mic oh you just boil it for Bart
he's already well I'm sorry I'm doing
the mask fundraiser right now and that's
taking priority I'm building Joe a gym
okay the Golf Papa golf yeah yeah you're
a human being thank you
no it's it comes out of selfishness I
was bored and I wanted a break
quarantine oh are you a lot of break
quarantine for some people what's
essential he's expanding this cartoon in
certain locations alright so here's a
video of one eccentric responding to
another eccentric here we go iris aside
from these three things has been a show
on Netflix called Tiger king yeah and
the man is the star of this is the
former Zoo owner who's serving a 22-year
prison sentence he's asking you for a
pardon saying he was unfairly convicted
your son yesterday jokingly said that he
was going to advocate for it and I was
wondering if you've seen the show and if
you have any thoughts on important Inc I
would look son must be done I had a
feeling it was time is that what he said
I don't know I know nothing about his 22
years for what what did he do allegedly
hired someone to murder an animal rights
activist but he said he didn't do that
and you didn't do it are you on his side
are you recommending a pardon no I'm not
advocating as a reporter you're not
allowed to do that you'd be criticized
by these would you recommend a pardon
I'm not wearing on time I don't think
you would
go ahead you have a question I'll take a
look is that Joe exotic that's jokes so
he's facing its way to your sentence now
Joe exotic yeah after the documentary
came out he's been in prison yeah the
the intro of the show was a video call
from and like the audio from him in
prison
oh you weren't paying attention dear
that wasn't the kid like Tyco on his
[ __ ] laugh oh yeah so this clip is
going viral on Twitter because a lot of
people are criticizing the president for
not watching Tiger king exactly that
really no one a lot of people are saying
you're the president how can you be
possibly talking about the tyre King
when the world is going through the
virus because someone exactly but like
so
so now predator president has not been a
fan favorite of the world and anything
he does is gonna be scrutinized by the
world and but surprising some people
have found him kind of amusing and the
fact that you know in this day and age
like he knows but if you looked at any
responsible leader ever in history or
like especially when they had like stuff
that's recorded if will go through
especially a time like this and somebody
asked him a question like that he's like
how the why would you and we focus on
the things that matter yeah do you see
them shun the other reporter for asking
a question about which we do do not make
people scared yeah yeah yeah please I
got parties your fake newsroom he like
blew up out of nowhere cuz I know the
question was just like what
inspirational thing do you have to say
to the American people
he's like how dare you ask a question
like that it was like I don't know maybe
get like a target key question is like
it's my son with the doctor for the
White House or whoever that is on his
side asking about like this one drug
that's not approved by the FDA that
they're heavily pushing that people like
it could kill a lot of people the
malaria one I don't know it's like he's
like well you have to lose the doctor
they see that's the doctor question
about it and he's like don't answer that
he's after that he's answer that and
move on move on because he doesn't want
that doctor to be like yeah we haven't
tested yeah but that's why my especially
a time like this
it's definitely funny but it's [ __ ] up
yeah a lot of people are asking for the
that reporter to be cancelled his name
is Stephen being a part of though it
would be like funny as [ __ ] you're like
you know it'd be great if I asked him
about Joe exotic like they imagine being
in that place as a reporter though you
know cuz everybody else is asking the
exact same questions you know I'm gonna
mix this [ __ ] up Joe exotic time I think
in the fact that his side was talking
about it and giving him a part I mean it
does relate how his son did also talk
about it like specifically right sure
he's really asking just about his son's
position and if you agree with your
son's position yeah basically that's
really was a scheme I think he's just
trying to get a pay raise but I got
their president and talking about Joe
exotic give me a [ __ ] pay raise I
think you like you know it'd be funny as
[ __ ] that's why I'm a Netflix I like
y'all like people from the Midwest are
watching Joe exotic you gotta like maybe
cuz everyone is like Joe exotic out
there they're like what that's not
normal
they did say like I think Texas has more
Tigers than anywhere else in the world
or something well in America man
captivity we have more Tigers than there
are in the world specifically probably
on that we in America like Texas
specifically but like I know that in
America there's a lot more captive
Tigers than there are wild tigers in the
world I'd be most of our in Texas are
probably most don't know Texas yeah why
they're doing because they're just so
dope to have you guys remember sig feat
in Roe and Freud or whatever sick
or yeah he's a frightened boy Roy Roy
roi uh uh but yeah I remember in Vegas
they they came out of their white
costumes and they [ __ ] did Tiger
shows and [ __ ] did one of them die
[ __ ] you by the time oh [ __ ] I forgot
that
where did he die or did you skip it I
don't remember I don't know but it was a
freak accident
and he smells sick free but and you know
what the MGM you know how their theme is
a lion there's like a well I don't know
about now but there was a lion
it's like area that you could just chill
oh yeah you can see them chillin on top
of the bubble yeah there's like a glass
tunnel you see they're nuts and [ __ ] and
yes you're walking across I don't know
there anymore don't think so cuz
everybody hates that animal [ __ ] yeah
yeah see that's what they should do is
we should take away porn from young
people so they don't get the same so
yeah so cuz I don't I don't get the cool
childhood that they have right now but
we should bring back the animals for
them because they don't get the zoo that
we get they don't get the SeaWorld that
we get they don't get the [ __ ]
animals and and cool theme parks like we
get all that captivity and torture and
[ __ ] those were good times those were
great times dude those animal activists
go way hard for animals that they would
rather have humans be [ __ ] up before
animals true like when the trainer's die
these animal people are like yeah which
is kind of fun there's no way to like
keep the elephants balancing on a ball
without beating them up like let's just
talk to the elephants pretty smart now I
I agree with that like like out they
used to like use them to make money off
that type of stuff but if Vilas ooh that
was like and they couldn't go back to
the wall and you gave them like a good
like a natural Safari yeah natural
Safari or sanctuary and then you also
have people that want to see them then I
think that's perfect do you charge you
charge money you charge money because
you need the money to help pay for the
alp
yeah we have those sanctuaries now I
think the problem is whipping the making
them balance or something
what about SeaWorld wouldn't they used
to do back flips and [ __ ] and now a lot
of those anyways because they they died
and they're not made to be in a tank
that's why sharks in like whales place
like a bajillion times I ever thought
about the from the perspective of a
whale guidance counselor where that
whale there like one day I could push it
to her potential he could do backflips
and that whale was down on them so that
I can't do no fat whoops
those trust me you really can and they
actually lived up to the potential and
did something that no natural whale can
do and then they killed their trainer
some people are very backstab you like
that they got reach to their potential
and then they killed their Jedi Master
yeah I would say that if I reincarnated
into a killer whale and my dream was to
be on a pool show doing backflips and
[ __ ] throwing water on children no
one's gonna hold me back from that dream
not even PETA
if you were a whale if I was a whale
what did you know you'd be a anti-peace
I look like a whale right now you know
it won't be any different for your
quarantine
that's true you'll be in the same spot
all day just [ __ ] backflip in and I
you know like I love sitting in the
front row cuz they'll [ __ ] shoot
water at you and then [ __ ] hit you
with the [ __ ] tail and stuff oh man
it was crazy there was no when I was a
kid I'm also with kids I liked I was a
kid can you imagine waking up at your
house you look out your window you see
Joe practicing to be a whale on your
pool and seeing my dolphins next to you
or like whales next - that's pretty dog
- like sir what would you like to be
when you grow up
oh really I want to be a Shamu show
there's a Nava trainer no I want to be
the whale if you had to be reincarnated
as an animal would you be
I told you already done that was that
movie the lobster that basically they're
like if you don't pass this course and
like get partnered up with like a
partner you get turned into an animal
seal a better chance of I am feral yeah
a weird movie I was cooler I liked I
liked it maybe a bird of some sort like
a bird
whoo flying we dou Y dou V dou P all
birds are cool man I would I would want
to be a horse a horse you want to get
ridden on run in the wild and let my
Mane [ __ ] fine the wind they have
wild horses in Nevada yeah in Montana
that's true lots just want to be a nice
desk though maybe you get caught
yeah well you could also live forever
why would you want that you stare at the
same rocks at the bottom of the ocean
for a hundred years you don't even get
to see the future technology change
everything still kind of looks the same
out there it might be fun if you like
that they like the same thing every day
if you like rocks yeah I want you to be
like a turtle where you could be on land
and say most people like you yeah and
then you live for like 400 years but
yeah I won't be a monkey cuz no other
animals jacks off you throw your poop at
people don't like French bulldogs
yourself really how I see the girls were
like standing there just rubbing the
[ __ ] I like your friend ain't actually
rubber yeah like that like with their
pop it's so funny cuz they look like fat
bats they do live like that no Joe you
should be one of the is it monkeys or is
it the Babu that go into the own sense
in Japan oh yeah the Japanese monkey
yeah you should be one of those it's
just our grandpa's are doing that
alright so to end of this video if
you're very interested
Roy and Siegfried Siegfried and Roy they
are still alive
it was a it was a target attack one of
them got their spine crushed oh my our
permanent Lee not able to speak or walk
very well they both of them or which one
Roy Roy all right Siegfried is okay so I
thought they died but their life you're
alive yeah you're making a biopic on
them though that's cool and and but I
guess because they're like Tigers are in
yeah a tiger's eye Oh it'd be a great
time to push the movie now yes
[Music]